I've said many times over the last six
months that if the Donald Trump
administration were colluding with
Russia it would look a lot like what
we're seeing he starts trying to ease
sanctions on Russia on day one of his
presidency constant line from Trump and
his associates about meetings and
contacts with Russian actors quickly
tries to return to seized Russian
compounds to Russia back during the
campaign
the Trump campaign was able to influence
a change in the Republican party
platform with regard to Trump and
Ukraine I'm sorry too Russia and Ukraine
that was very favorable to Vladimir
Putin he spilled classified information
obtained from an ally of ours Israel two
Russian diplomats in the Oval Office and
now Donald Trump has done something else
that Putin has wanted for a while but
it's actually something that I agree
with on policy although it exposes the
further corruption and sort of puppetry
puppeteering that is going on by
Vladimir Putin of Donald Trump Donald
Trump has decided to end a covert
program which was arming rebels in Syria
fighting against Bashar al-assad now
let's break this down into its component
parts Russia and Putin and the Kremlin
have wanted the United States to stop
helping anti-assad rebels for a very
very long time so this decision by Trump
plays right into Putin hands US
officials have confirmed that Russia has
been trying to get the us to stop arming
anti-assad rebels for a long time and
now six months into Trump's presidency
apparently a month after Trump initially
thought about doing this and just about
10 days after Donald Trump met with
Putin in Germany and talked about the
serious situation Trump kills the
program okay this is the right move this
is the right move I have been critical
of for a very long time
these picking of sides moves by the
United States and the Pentagon Defense
Department foreign policy CIA in
tell agencies where we are sort of
picking sides in the internal battles of
other countries and this is backfired on
us many times it's backfired on us in
the Middle East it's backfired on us in
in Latin America I know a lot about that
being from Argentina and I actually
believe that it's a bad idea for the
United States to employ these types of
policies and it often ends up with our
own weapons being used against us or our
allies I've talked a lot about that so I
if you were to come to me and say David
what's the best thing that Donald Trump
has done during his presidency I would
probably say it's this stopping that
program however do you think for a
second that Donald Trump has any idea
about the the details and and minutiae
and implications of this Trump has no
idea about anything other than a talking
point or two that he might be able to
remember for five or ten minutes before
he takes the stage somewhere or starts a
debate so while I believe this is the
correct decision and it has nothing to
do with who makes it right this is I
believe a good decision this is yet
another item on the list of ways in
which Donald Trump is doing everything
Vladimir Putin wants and Trump did this
without getting anything in return
at least that we're aware of although
maybe what he got in return came a few
months ago which was helped from
Vladimir Putin and Russia and the
Kremlin and Russian hackers in helping
get him elected in the first place and I
think it's really important we need
nuance right this is the right decision
it is not at all indicative of Donald
Trump's broader foreign policy
perspective or how he sees the u.s. role
within geopolitics there's nothing
nuanced here it's yet another win for
Vladimir Putin and for everybody who
keeps saying if Russia helps Trump
they've gotten nothing out of the deal
you could not be more wrong at this
point am I missing something here
let me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show follow us there we'll be back after
this today's sponsor is tagging
the hosting specialists whatever your
hosting needs for your business or
project taga dab can do it dedicated
servers virtual private servers cloud
server solutions colocation custom
server solutions and the big thing at
taga dab is their customer support over
70% of their business comes from repeat
orders and recommendations from existing
customers this is a testament to the
great support that they give their
customers currently rated a nine point
seven out of ten according to the
Trustpilot
review system with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab currently offers our viewers
and listeners a twenty british pound
free credit about twenty four US dollars
to all new customers that sign up gives
you a chance to try the service this is
a limited availability offer for the
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show
to take advantage go to sign up CAG
adapt comm /td PS and use the offer code
TDPS
20 during account registration support
our sponsors and support our show in
doing so sign up ta ga da be com /t DPS
coupon code is TDPS 20